dentro de tres meses fumarse una calada
así ya no será legal en algunas zonas de
ámsterdam a partir de mediados de mayo
será ilegal fumar sustancias en las
calles del barrio Der walen de la ciudad
más conocido como el barrio rojo la
prohibición se produce en un intento de
la ciudad de reprimir el comportamiento
antisocial de los turistas e intenta
mejorar la calidad de vida de los
residentes muchos de los cuales se
quejan desde hace tiempo de las
molestias causadas por el humo la ciudad
ha amenazado con ir aún más lejos para
reprimir el comportamiento de los
turistas
si las molestias no disminuyen lo
suficiente con la prohibición de fumar
se estudiará también la posibilidad de
prohibir fumar en las Terrazas de los
cafés de la zona
casi todos los concejales apoyaron tomar
medidas en una votación celebrada el
jueves el ayuntamiento también anunció
que los restaurantes y bares tendrán que
cerrar a las 2 de la madrugada los
viernes y sábados y los trabajadores
sexuales tendrán que cerrar sus locales
a las 3 de la madrugada
los vecinos llevan años pidiendo cambios
como este y para un dirigente local Ya
era hora además de las nuevas leyes el
ayuntamiento de amsterdam lanzará una
campaña de alejamiento dirigida a los
turistas que viajan a la capital en
busca de drogas alcohol o sexo